bonjour et merci d'être avec nous alors
on vient d'entendre le garde des sceaux
avec elle cette annonce l'école de la
magistrature soit érigée par une femme
l'avocate nathalie rhorer c'est une
première elle n'est pas issue de
magistrature elle c'est une femme
peut-être une réaction oui effectivement
nathalie rhorer est d'abord en toute
chose une femme de qualité pense que
elle a su depuis qu'elle existe
bâtonnière s'imposer comme une belle
femme qui a les compétences et qui est
reconnu comme tel par ses pairs donc ce
choix là effectivement très opportun
après se pose la question de l'utilité
d'une nomination d'un avocat à la
présidence de l'école nationale de la
magistrature
nous sommes dans un climat qui est assez
il faut bien le reconnaître assez
délétère avec les magistrats relais les
incidents sont malheureusement multiples
au quotidien dans les salles d'audience
et à l'extérieur et donc on peut espérer
que la nomination d'une avocate au sein
de cette école parviennent à apaiser les
tensions et à faire en sorte que les
deux professions apprennent un peu à
s'apprivoiser
ah bein is you je note d'ailleurs que
dans l'histoire à l'école de formation
des barreaux du barreau de paris avait
déjà été présidée par un magistrat de
l'ordre administratif
la réforme de l'école nationale de la
magistrature c'est selon le nouveau
garde des sceaux pour avoir une
séparation claire entre les magistrats
du siège et les magistrats du parquet
pourquoi selon vous quel est le problème
la difficulté c'est que les magistrats
du parquet et du siège ont deux
fonctions totalement différente
le magistrat du siège va juger une
personne individu est un magistrat du
parquet ce sont les procureurs de la
république
ils vont donc les poursuivre et il est
assez délicat d'avoir une promiscuité
entre ces deux corps puisque cela jette
un doute systématique sur l'impartialité
de l'un et de l'autre et donc en cela le
garde des sceaux avait tout à fait
raison de vouloir une réforme qui
permette la séparation de ses deux deux
types de magistrats site en tête le
magistrat du parquet est bien un
magistrat puisque la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme l'uab de renier cette
qualité est encore quelques années
ceci étant dit la nomination de madame
forest ne va pas avoir d'impact concret
sur 7 sur cette volonté de séparer ces
deux corps alors on attendait du
ministre de la justice
il dévoile les grands chantiers de sa
réforme est ce que c'est vraiment ça qui
est en train de se passer actuellement
vous avez raison le souligner c'est
assez décevant finalement cette annonce
je pense que si elle est positive elle
est néanmoins largement insuffisante
on nous parlait d'une réforme en
profondeur structurelles qui allait
permettre une séparation des fonctions
de parquets et de sièges
et comme je le disais à l'instant la
nomination de notre consoeur aurait
aussi est bénéfique soit elle ne va pas
avoir une conséquence sur ce terrain là
donc ça donne le sentiment en réalité
que que la garde des sceaux n'a pas
grande latitude ans dans la conduite des
récentes qu'il souhaitait mener et qui
fait ce qu'il peut avec les moyens du
bord alors réformer l'école nationale de
la magistrature est ce que c'est le seul
point qu'il faudrait effectuer un pour
réformer la justice française on va
revenir encore une fois sur la question
de l'indépendance des magistrats du
parquet qui est une question qui revient
à chaque dossier politique ou financier
c'est une question qui n'est pas du tout
résolu on la met sur la table on fait
semblant de la découvrir à chaque
nouveau dossier mais au final rien n'est
fait pour s'atteler réellement à cette
ré sol et c'est me semble-t-il à l'une
des priorités plus que tu devrais être
en tout cas l'une des priorités un
ancien avocat comme eric dupond-moretti
brief caussade merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions et avoir été en direct sur
rt franc je rappelle que vous êtes
membre de l'union des jeunes avocats de
paris merci